foreign
[Music]
I went out you know and I never thought
that I would be back here now I'm just
trying to matter and live a good life
and make work that means something to
somebody and you have all made me feel
that I might have accomplished that
tonight I told the history teacher of my
plan and he said Fox you're never gonna
be cute forever
I had no idea how to respond to that
I found desire for what I do early in my
life and I'm lucky because I had people
who encouraged that desire the people
who taught me good or bad how to fail
how to love I would not be standing here
if it weren't for Mr Wally Farnsworth
was my High School Drama teacher I have
to thank everyone from the very onset of
my career Mr Kaden Jones Kevin misher
and and Stacy Snyder and Stacy shear and
I can't believe I'm remembering
everybody's name but believing that I
could do it and now tonight I have this
I'm gonna find you all individually and
I'm gonna thank you along with my
friends who I love so much I'm gonna hug
the hell out of you when the feeling
re-enters my body whatever it is we look
up to whoever it is we're chasing to
that I say all right all right all right
you just gotta keep living man
[Music]